POI flowers POI hybrids POI
isolations what do all these po moves
have in common well it's a little thing
called po driving Styles and in this
video I'm going to break down for you
what exactly they are and why they're so
important Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain in today I'm going to
give you a deep dive into a topic in po
spinning that once upon a time uh I was
a little bit of a skeptic of but I have
to admit I have become a convert to over
the years but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyro Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- bus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so
obvious question what exactly is a
driving style the word was coined by
French po spinner Olive to describe the
different ways in which POI can move
relative to an arm depending upon how
much energy is put into it and in which
direction and cards on table in the past
I have definitely been a proponent of
saying that this is a concept that we
didn't actually need in the poy
world and I've come back around to the
point where I think actually it does
serve a very valuable purpose see I
personally think that teaching beginners
how to add and subtract momentum to the
poy as they're spinning it is a really
really useful tool that comes in handy
for a variety of techniques down the
road and more than that it will give
them more confidence and control of the
poy earlier on so with that in mind I'm
going to take you through all five
unique po driving Styles in the course
of this
video driving style number one
extensions so arguably extensions are
the very first driving style that we
ever learn as POI Spinners because I
would actually count just spinning the
poy around the hand that is a static
spin as a form of an extension the idea
here is that we're trying to produce
circles in which the PO is an extension
of the hand hence the very clever name
right and this has all sorts of
applications not just from getting down
basic hand motions and timing and
Direction but also for practicing moves
such as real turns as well as
butterflies but more than that I think
it's in our best interest to teach
beginners as they're learning how to
spin POI how to think of the poison
extension of their arm sooner rather
than later and not kind of as a separate
object not only does that lead to
Greater fluency with the prop but also
it leads to Greater ability to move with
it and I think it has to be said this is
a very underrated but important tool to
give beginners if you can think of the
Poise being extensions of your arms then
your spatial awareness when it comes to
moving around your arms kicks in and it
makes so many po tricks easier to learn
and I think that extensions are really
well teamed with the next driving Style
on this list
namely driving style number two
pendulums so arguably if there is a pyri
on this list that might not belong here
it's going to be this one if for no
other reason then I think that we could
just as easily frame it as a cap that is
being a product of two different driving
Styles put together but that's not how
we learn this trick most of us in
learning pendulums don't think of it as
going back and forth between portions of
a shape that is anti-spin and portions
that are extensions despite the fact
that this is exactly what this is on
paper instead we think of this as being
robbing the poy of energy to make sure
that it never swings above our hand as
we take it around in a
circle see by learning all the different
driving Styles you learn a lot about how
much energy you put into the POI and how
much you can take away and that becomes
a really important factor when you're
learning POI flowers as well as putting
together the different shapes on this
list into things like hybrids and caps
and the like this concept turns out to
be super important and it's this
property of pendulums that is what I
think makes them so important if with
extensions we learned how to use our
body awareness to keep the PO moving
where we wanted it to go learning
pendulums also gives us the ability to
control just how much Nuance there is to
that movement one of my my favorite
exercises to give beginner students is
to go back and forth between extensions
and pendulums in all the different
timing and Direction modes not only does
this give them a feel for keeping that
timing and Direction consistent but also
it shows them exactly how much or how
little energy they can put into the POI
to switch the driving style super
important for transitions down the road
so with these two bedrocks under our
belt I'm going to take you into the
realm of what I think most people think
of when they refer to driving Styles
starting with
driving style number three inpin
flowers all right so we do have to say
right at the jump that arguably
extensions and inpin flowers are both
kind of the same thing in some ways we
can honestly think of an extension as
basically being a zero beat inpin flower
uh for more information on that I did a
video on the mathematics of poi flowers
that I'll go ahead and link to down in
the description and up in the cards but
for the time being let's just say for
the sake of argument that they're
different because the experience of
learning them can be very different for
beginners ins spin flowers are usually
the first type of poi flowers that
beginners become acquainted with and
it's easy to see why that relationship
with extensions means that if you've got
your extensions down inpin flowers are
next logical step and they're also the
first time that you're working in a
system in which you have to do more
beats with the poy than you do with your
hands and that is a really crucial skill
to get down depending on whether you're
going to do two pedals three p pedals or
four petals inpin flowers become a point
at which we have to control exactly how
fast the PO is spinning relative to our
hands this is an invaluable skill to
pick up and one that is going to be
really really important for the next
driving style in the list which of
course as POI flowers go for every in
spin there
is driving style number four anti-spin
flowers so this is the PO flower that
everybody wants to get down those long
narrow petals just look so beautiful
especially when you can see them with
Trails this is also the first time on
this list that we've worked in a place
where the PO is explicitly spinning in
the opposite direction that the hand is
see anti-spin flowers actually take
something that we were playing around
with in our INSP spin section that is
controlling the number of Beats that the
poy does relative to the hand and kind
of turns it inside out not only do you
have to control how fast the PO is
spinning but also you have to do that in
a space where it's spinning in the
opposite direction that your hand is
going that in and of itself can be a
huge Challenge and of course there's a
variety of ways in which this can
manifest everything from six petal
anti-spin flowers to four petal
anti-spin flowers three petal anti-spin
flowers and into that wild and crazy
world of just two petal anti-spin
flowers depending on how you want to
look at it either being linear
isolations or cat eyes and hey real
quickly if you want to get more videos
on PO tricks and technique please make
sure to subscribe to the channel channel
so you see all my videos as soon as they
get posted all right so after extensions
pendulums inpin flowers and anti-spin
flowers you might be asking what could
possibly come next and well that is the
biggest challenge on this
list driving style number five
isolations so you can basically think of
isolations as being extensions turned
inside out and this is the biggest
reason why I said that static spins were
basically extensions because when we
learn how to do isolations it's like
we're starting over from scratch in
terms of how to get the PO to move along
with the hand if anything I think that
pendulums are probably the closest
neighbor to isolations on this list but
really when you get down to it you could
also say what happens at the tip of
inpin and anti-spin pedals also feels a
lot like an
isolation and just to nerd out even
harder for a second they also have
something in common with extensions and
that they're both single beat patterns
that is the poy completes one beat for
every beat that the hand does just so
happens to be that in an extension the
PO is always pointed away out from the
center of the body and in isolations the
PO is always pointed the opposite
direction that the hand is in and this
results in what is easily the most
challenging and also probably the most
useful of all the driving Styles the
things that you have to learn in order
to maintain this motion are absolutely
essential to getting down other hybrids
and stalls and of course the real
challenge that comes with the knowledge
of all these different driving Styles is
being able to practice and perform all
of them in all the timing and Direction
modes one of my favorite drills to give
people is to start off with pendulums
and then work your way up to extensions
and then inpin flowers before working
your way back down again here you learn
how to add and subtract momentum to the
poy and this is really helpful for
making
Transitions and of course you can
combine together the results of any two
driving styles to get poy hybrids some
of them may be more recognizable than
others but each and every one of them is
going to be a fun challenge to get your
hands to perform together and hey if you
looking to get a leg up on your
fundamental po skills I've got great
news for you because that is the topic
of the flow Circle for the month of July
the flow circle is an exclusive lesson
that's available only to my supporters
on patreon that gets delivered straight
to your inbox this month the theme is
exercises that will help you get down
these fundamental po skills everything
from drilling those Tic Tacs and
different planer orientations to
developing hand Independence so you can
perform a zero point with one hand and
not the other a crucial skill for
getting down transitions sign up now
over at patreon.com / drexfactor poy the
first lesson is already up cool so those
are what I would consider to be the five
fundamental driving styles of Po if you
like me are a PO nerd out there I'd love
to hear did I miss anything things that
you would consider to be a fundamental
driving style did I add too many things
to the list leave me a comment and let
me know also be sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video and to help my channel
grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all rock thank you so
much and if you out there watching are
not currently supporters but you'd like
to become supporters you can do that by
heading on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards but even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you and if you
all would like to learn more about poy
hybrids I did a great explainer video a
couple years ago that I will link to
down in the description as well as up on
screen that will take you through every
single type of poy hybrid that I was
aware of when I made that video it's
quite long but very thorough um either
way thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace